[Music]
melissa joins us from fort worth texas
melissa welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely how can john and i help
hi um so i recently were i was looking
at my credit score
and i noticed
a couple credit cards that
i didn't know about they
there was five of them and the only
person that i can think of that has my
social security is my mother
i confronted her about these cards
she confirmed that she took them out i
was not aware
of any of this
um so i'm just calling to kind of just
get some advice on like what i should do
about this situation yikes um what's
your relationship with your mom
um we're really close um not as close as
you thought
i know yeah
um so
i just yeah i just recently found out a
couple weeks ago and so
just kind of figuring out what was her
what was her reasoning from for
violating your trust like this from
stealing from her daughter
um she told me that
they were kind of struggling with money
and
at the time like my credit score was
actually you know decent
um and so she
she was just used like those credit
cards that you get in the mail type of
thing
just kind of applied to those the
easiest way um does she have
some any kind of addiction what is she
spending all this money on
um she was just saying she didn't i
didn't really in the moment i didn't ask
exactly why i was just kind of just hurt
by the situation um
but um she was just saying that she was
in a really bad place
and this was really struggling
financially
and
that's what she did um so melissa
um i'm not gonna talk bad about your mom
i will a little bit but
i'm not gonna i'm gonna talk more about
this this full picture here okay
okay
your trust
and the sanctity of your social security
number was stolen from you and
compromised a crime was committed
you got that
yes and i know that's hard but your
mother committed a crime and you are the
victim
and i definitely yeah i would this would
be such a major trust violation for me
because it was it was done behind your
back with full knowledge that they were
stealing from you
and um
there's two people on the planet that
can't ever do that and that's mom and
dad right
yeah yeah i agree so if i'm you
i would
go to the social security number office
and change my number
i would tell my mom this is a major
trust violation major and it's going to
cost you a bunch of of mess and if you
have to pay for it i would tell her
because you have i
i've lost your trust and i have to go do
this i'm asking you to pay for any of
the fines and fees or whatever it's
going to cost to change my social
security number
i would let my mom know you cannot have
this and if there is any sort of
anything
then the next step is i'm going to file
a police report and i know that sounds
really rough because that's your mom and
you got to understand that you are
simply responding to a crime that was
committed
and
not like being ugly to your mom your mom
started this and now she dropped this in
your lap and you have to create the
boundaries and deal with this
yeah right and i know that's so hard
because you thought you had a good
relationship with your mom you're gonna
have to grieve that relationship because
it's not what you thought it was
yeah
and i hate that for
you it's okay um it's hey hey no it's
not it's not okay
because i get how i mean i'm just
thinking if i was to show up and do this
i can't even wrap my head around how
heartbroken i would be if i found out my
mom had done this
yeah it's a big deal that's kind of what
i've been processing that's right
melissa you also need to go ahead and
freeze your credit with all three
bureaus so that no one including your
mom can open any kind of trade lines
with your name and social security
number that is your a1 do you currently
use a credit card
yeah i currently have one um and so it
was like recently and um kind of knew it
looking at my credit and stuff and so
when i saw the cards i was just like
whoa i almost have one
yeah and when i saw the others i was
like
yeah that's actually a great point
george i would pull my credit is there
any other charges
uh like is there a home equity loan
taken out on
with your credit card or is there other
lines of credit no no no no no no
i started looking at everything else no
it's just it's five cards okay how much
debt is on is on your account now
um all the cards collectively is about 6
000. okay well she needs to to pay that
off whether that's giving you the money
because you have access to the account
that's probably the safest way to do it
but i don't want these lingering going
to collections all under your name on
your record
so yeah you've got some cleanup today
is she gonna does she have the money to
pay you
um that's when i i had a conversation
with her about it i told her that i want
her to pay for all this
not i want i don't i don't i personally
don't want to i feel like i shouldn't no
no
no
you're not paying a dime of this no
you're that's what you have 60 days to
get 6 000 or i'm gonna have to make a
police report because i gotta go get
another social security number and i
gotta file on my credit report that
these are fraudulent charges
that's what i would do yeah that's a
firm boundary and that your mom will say
oh my gosh you're gonna do that to us
we're struggling yes
because if you'd asked me for six
thousand dollars and said we are broke
and we were starving you might have been
able to help but you stole from me
you stole from me and now you change the
the the relationship boundaries here
gee i'd give her a deadline i didn't
even think about that george i'm sorry i
i missed that you you've got yeah she's
got to pay this back in this time frame
and then we're we're we're changing
directions here yeah i mean it's either
she pays up or there's legal
ramifications because you're not
touching that yeah because then she's
going to go oh sweet that was a free six
grand i just got on that sweatshirt
yeah she's going to go take out a car
loan because the car is going to break
and she'll just get a note but honey
she'll pay you and there's no end to
where this thing ends because she's got
your number she's got your ticket
and it's going to be a pain to go change
your social security number across all
of your different forms and this is and
that's and that's the world you're in
and i hate that for you but it happened
yeah tough situation